apple's new m2 chip for the mac is
coming sooner than you think potentially
as soon as a rumored march 8 apple event
according to various sources including
mark german who just put out a new
report over the weekend that is probably
the most important confirmation we've
received to this day but what makes
everything really confusing is that he
also expects multiple macs to come out
later this year that are actually based
on the m1 pro and m1 max chips that we
already have and the problem this
creates is that a lot of people are
going to be very confused when it comes
to understanding the differences between
the m1 pro max chips and the new m2 chip
because based on the number two it seems
like it should be a much faster chip but
that's actually far from the truth so
before i get into all of the technical
details and leaks including giving you
guys estimated benchmarks for the
performance of the m2 compared to the
original m1 and the m1 pro max chips i
want to cover exactly what mark german
said in his report and why it proves
that the m2 chip is coming sooner than
we expected the first point i want to
make is that mark believes that there
will be multiple macs appearing next
month at apple's event and that's based
on recent filings in the eec database
where apple registered three brand new
mac models including a laptop and if you
watched our recent video covering these
three new macs i concluded that there's
a pretty good chance that the entry
level m2 macbook pro is actually going
to be revealed at next month's event and
that's based on multiple sources like
when digitimes randomly claimed that an
m2 macbook pro would be coming next
month when at the time it made zero
sense and then after that the leaker who
was the only one that predicted that the
new 14 and 16 inch macbook pros would
have a notch
also claimed that the new m2 macbook pro
would be coming next month which lines
up to the new eec filings that show one
new laptop and two desktop mac machines
coming soon and then we also had an
older mark german report where he
claimed that the m2 chip would debut on
the macbook pro instead of the macbook
air like many people believed and then
now in his new report he also agrees
that the new macbook pro will keep the
same 13 inch design but get an upgraded
m2 chip sitting below the 14 and 16 inch
macbook pro and if this is in fact true
that it's getting the old design then it
really needs to get released asap
because it wouldn't make sense to
release an old design alongside the full
macbook air redesign that everyone is
expecting in fall of this year so with
that said there's a pretty good chance
that apple is going to be revealing this
new m2 chip at the upcoming march event
and even if they don't it should be
coming no later than october guaranteed
but the most important thing that we
have to discuss in this video is the
difference between the m2 chip and the
m1 pro and m1 max chips because mark
german also believes that we'll be
seeing both low end m2 and high end m1
pro max mac mini models coming out this
year potentially both at this upcoming
march event so without further ado let's
get right into those differences
according to mark german he believes
that the m2 chip will probably be a bit
speedier than the m1 while retaining the
same 8-core cpu architecture but on the
graphics side it's going to be getting a
boost from 7 or 8 cores to 9 or 10. so
what he's basically saying is that the
m2 chip will be a direct upgrade to the
original m1 chip with no changes to the
cpu core layout itself but instead
focusing on raising the clock speeds of
each core to improve the performance
while also potentially making other
updates like adding more cash or
upgrading other parts of the chip like
the machine learning accelerators the
neural engine the video encoders and
decoders and other things like that now
in contrast the m1 pro and m1 max chips
are a completely different beast because
they only have two efficiency cores
instead of four but instead they have
double the number of performance cores
eight instead of four which basically
means that it's hyper focused on high
performance workloads while the regular
m2 is going to be focused on efficiency
and even though the new m2 chip is
expected to get either 9 or 10 graphic
scores it's still nowhere near the m1
pro chips 14 or 16 graphics cores let
alone the m1 max's 32 gpu course and
because of this i can guarantee you that
the m1 pro chip will still be faster
than the m2 chip in terms of raw
multi-core cpu and gpu performance even
though the m2 will have the latest chip
architecture as i'm gonna show you in
just a minute and this is very important
to understand because apple's current m1
pro and m1 max chips are positioned and
marketed as the highest performance
chips that are currently only in apple's
14 and 16-inch macbook pros which start
at 2 000
compared to the m1 chip which you can
get for as low as 650
on a brand new m1 mac mini from amazon
and since the m2 chip will directly
replace the m1 it'll only be going into
apple's lower end products like the
entry level m2 macbook pro the macbook
air the low end mac mini and the 24 inch
imac and if you're looking at it from
that perspective it makes total sense
for the much more expensive max to also
be much faster in terms of performance
even if they still technically have m1
based pro and max chips instead of the
new m2 but the next point i want to get
into is that raw performance is not
going to be the only difference the new
m1 pro and max chips got some major
additional upgrades like for example
coming with ultra fast ssds which can
give you speeds of up to 7 400 megabytes
per second making them literally the
fastest ssds in the industry but looking
at the ssds that come with the m1 max
they're limited to around 3 300
megabytes per second basically two times
slower and in my opinion the new m2 max
will continue to use these slower ssds
because they're meant for regular
consumers who don't need anything faster
than that and then going even further
the m1 pro and max chips also boasts
incredibly high memory bandwidth up to
400 gigabytes per second compared to the
original m1 chips 68 gigabytes per
second which is almost six times slower
and the reason for that is the fact that
the m1 not only uses slower ram but it's
also running on a 128 bit memory bus
instead of 256 bits on the m1 pro and
max chips and then on top of that
another reason is that you can only get
up to 16 gigs of ram on the m1 compared
to up to 64 with the m1 max so in my
opinion even though i expect the m2 chip
to come with faster ram than what comes
in the m1
i don't think it'll be nearly as fast as
the ram that comes with the m1 pro and
m1 max chips and i'm also pretty sure
that the m2 will still come with only 8
gigabytes of ram at the base price and
it'll be limited to the same 16 gigs as
before so the point that i'm making is
that even though the m2 chip will sound
like it's better the m1 pro and max
chips will still have major performance
advantages including raw power ssd speed
and ram speed as well among other
differences like the m1 max actually
coming with two video encoders as well
as two sets of prores encoders slash
decoders while i fully expect the m2
chip to stick with just one and now with
that said the last thing we've got to
cover is the performance benchmark
estimates to show you guys the real
world differences and before i get into
the charts i want to mention that while
everyone is expecting the m2 chip to be
based on last year's a15 bionic iphone
chip i actually think there's a chance
that it could be based on this year's
future a16 chip instead and if you're
wondering why i think that would happen
be sure to watch this video where i laid
out all of my reasoning for the m2 being
based on the a16 instead of the a15 but
because we don't know that for sure just
yet i'm gonna give you guys the
performance numbers for both of these
scenarios to give you a better idea of
the possibilities so with that said the
first benchmark we have is geekbench
five single core test where the m2 chip
will actually have an awesome
performance boost over the m1 chips
which could help for things like common
web browsing and this result is because
of using the new chip architecture based
on newer chip technology from tsmc but
moving over to the multi-core
performance you can see that even in the
best case scenario for the m2 chip it's
still slower than the bend 8 core m1 pro
chip which is exactly what apple wants
since they wouldn't want the cheaper m2
to be faster and then finally for the
graphics side of things we can see the
exact same thing the bend 14 core m1 pro
is still quite a bit faster than the new
10 core version of the m2 in both
scenarios so as you can see the new m2
chip should give us a decent improvement
over the original m1 but there's no way
that it can cannibalize the sales of the
higher end machines with the m1 pro and
max since it's still a ways away
especially if you consider the
differences in the expected ssd and ram
performance as well as the differences
in the number of video encoders and
decoders with the pro and max chips so
there you guys go hopefully you now
fully understand the differences between
the m2 and the current m1 pro and max
chips and if you learned something new
in this video go ahead and click the
circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out our m2 mac leaks right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you